The FCC has increasingly become a force for
evil under the trump administration, not the
least of which is because of their opposition
to net neutrality regulations, which as you
know from the Obama era, have been repealed
by trump's FCC.
And the big news this week, this is a major
story and it's not getting as much coverage
as it should, partially because some people
don't recognize how big it is. Partially,
there were like 10 other scandals in the last
48 hours. The big news is that the FCC has
admitted this week. It wasn't actually hacked.
You might remember that back during the public
comment period around the net neutrality repeal,
the FCC said we are going to have a period
of, I don't remember how many weeks it was
during which people can write in and they
can tell us, we want you to repeal of net
neutrality, or we don't want you to repeal
net neutrality. And the FCC claimed that Adidas
attack a denial of service attack, a hack
took down the public comment system. And as
a result, the system went down, right? We
got hacked. The system went down.
We can't take public comments, sorry. However,
former verizon lawyer and current FCC, chairman,
Ajit Pai has now admitted there was no hack.
It simply wasn't true. And here's the just
absolute goldmine. A gte pie is blaming the
Obama administration. Because even though
the lie was made during the trump administration
and by the trump FCC, while trying to repeal
Obama era, net neutrality regulations, a gte
Pi says that the trump fcc inherited a culture
from the Obama administration, which led to
the lying, so listen, it's basically Obama,
so Obama might as well have been personally
lying as far as the GTE is concerned here.
Thanks Obama. He did it again. What happened
to personal responsibility? What happened
to the buck? Stops with the person at the
top and the FCC and a jeep Pi have been repeating
this lie for a year or more at this point
that a hack took down the comments system.
So tons of people who wanted to comment about
the net neutrality repeal couldn't, and it
just wasn't true. The FCC inspector general
investigated found that the claim of a hack
was a total lie, and of course the real reason
that the system went down, there's sort of
two possibilities. One is much worse than
the other. Okay? Possibility. One is that
so many millions of Americans were against
the net neutrality repeal that they wanted
to make their voices heard, period, and that
led to so much traffic that the comment section
went down on the FCC website. That's like
the less sinister explanation. The more sinister
explanation is that the FCC took down the
comments section to prevent those comments
from being made in the first place and we
don't know which one it is. As far as the
so called apology goes. This could be one
of the most bogus apologies we've heard recently.
I apologize for the fact that an Obama person
lied. The followup part of this is whether
a gte Pi knew he was lying all along a gte
pies saying that's a conspiracy theory. He
included in his statement about this, the
following quote. I'm pleased that this report
debunks the conspiracy theory that my officer,
I had any knowledge that the information provided
by the former cio was inaccurate and was allowing
that inaccurate information to be disseminated
for political purposes. We'll see whether
that's a conspiracy theory. It's kind of hard
for me to believe that a gte pie and the higher
ups at the FCC, we're told this is a hack.
They had a ton of data to review related to
whether it was a hack. They looked at the
data presumably, and they still came away
thinking it was a hack when there was no actual
evidence that they got hacked. I don't know
that. I believe that a gte pie wasn't just
parroting something he knew wasn't true.
Yeah. Science show. I think that this was
taken down deliberately and then you'd have
to hold the GPI accountable for that and just
it goes to this bigger picture that even though
it's the FCC and they're the government, they're
supposed to be working for the people. They
don't really care what you have to say. If
you disagree with them, they'll take you down,
they'll shut you down. They just want to listen
to the corporate interests. That's
bummer. At the bottom line, which is we're
sort of debating over what was the reason
why people against repealing net neutrality
weren't able to make the comments. The truth
is that even if they were able to make the
comments, it was getting repealed either way,
right? Like the FCC never cared what public
opinion was they and eat pie are tools of
the NCTA, the cable lobby and the ISP and
everybody else who has a financial interest
in repealing net neutrality and it's silly
to even pretend like, oh, you know, if they
had just gotten 500,000 or a million more
comments against the repeal, they wouldn't
have appealed it. Of course not. They were
repeating it no matter what, and I want actually
want to take it a step further and this is
something that his resignation worthy in my
mind when we talk about creeping authoritarianism
and the authoritarian slide under the trump
administration.
It's really scary to realize that a federal
agency can lie to everybody about what happened,
possibly knowingly used that lie to say that
they or to defect effectively ignore the opposition
to what they're doing, which is the killing
of net neutrality. They later admit that it
was a lie, but they get to keep the repeal
as if the light is irrelevant and the truth
is that in the end the lie is irrelevant because
the comments were going to be irrelevant and
a jeep pie should be fired. The buck should
stop with him. Personal responsibility. He's
in charge. Blaming the culture of the Obama
Administration for this is a joke, and at
worst they took down the comments section,
which is a form of if they did it deliberately,
government limiting free expression.
Well, the GPI could in theory be impeached
by the Senate. Only problem is those senators
are also bought and paid for by the ISP, the
telecoms.
I would not hold my breath for even 10 seconds
hoping that the, the, the Republican Senate
is going to punish a gte pie for lying. That
is, I mean it's a I. it's inconceivable that
that would take place. So are you surprised
about this? Not Really A. Are we dismayed
by it? We are, but it just yet another instance
of this decided and definitive creep towards
authoritarianism and a government that eliminates
checks and balances. Ignores the will of the
people and this is what we've got to look
forward to. If Democrats don't take over the
House and Senate in 2018, and certainly if
Donald Trump is reelected in 20 slash 20,
it is going to continue creeping to the point
where we might call it. What's the next thing
after creeping walking? I don't know. I think
it's there. It's there. You're just an authoritarian
as we will eventually get there. That's exactly
right. Discuss this with us on the David Pakman
show, sub Reddit, David Pakman.com/r e d d
I t, and if you're not following the show
on instagram at David Pakman show, please
do. I will be answering questions there after
today's show. So
question at David Pakman show on instagram
the David Pakman
show at David Pakman Dotcom.